Des familles déplacées
font déjà la file au soleil au l
pour des vêtements
et de la nourriture.
mais surtout du sud.
Comme des,
ils ont réussi à fuir
l'occupation russe,
Et ce sont leur village,
leur patrimoine, que l'armée
ukrainienne tente aujourd'hui
depuis six mois en territoire
contrôlé par les Russes,
près de Melitopol.
il y a exactement une semaine.
"Ma famille était en danger,
parce mon mari est
un militaire", dit-elle.
(détonation)ion)ion)ion)
"Il est resté pour se battre,
et il participe aujourd'hui
à la vaste contre-offensive
lancée par l'armée ukrainienne
dans le sud du pays."
Le président Volodymyr Zelensky
hier soir avait lancé
un ultimatum aux soldats du
: capituler ou mourir.
Depuis, de violents combats
secouent la région de Kherson,
capturée par l'armée russe
au tout début de l'invasion.
Et nous avons réussi ce matin
à joindre Ira.
Elle est barricadée
dans son appartement,
seule et effrayée.
Il y a beaucoup d'explosions
depuis d même au
centre-ville, ou elle dit que
les Ukrainiens ont bombardé un
immeuble qui servait d'hôpital
militaire à l'armée russe.
usieurs sources,
l'armée ukrainienne aurait percé
la première ligne du front russe
et libéré quelques villages.
Oleksandr, qui est lui aussi
de Kherson, se morfond
en attendant des nouvelles
du front et de ses enfants.
Il appréhende le carnage
et la destruction de sa ville
natale. Tamara s'ajoute
à la discussion et prie
pour la libération de Kherson.
Elle est une survivante
de Marioupol et dit qu'elle
ne s'en remettra jamais...
d'avoir eu à enterrer sa nièce
et un bébé de quatre mois.
"Tout ce qu'on veue
ça finisse, ne serait-ce que
pour les enfants", dit-elle
Ces enfants, que la guerre suit,
même quand ils la fuient.
On leur s Legos,
ils en font des fusils.
Ici Tamara Alteresco,
Radio-C